would you prefer would you prefer a guy
that you could trust his judgment like
have you can you think of a man like in
your life at all that you like genuinely
if he told you not to do something you
would do it just because you respect him
so much
one person maybe
um so it's like that type of respect
like I'll give you an example my my dad
um I respect him so much I do my
accounting and I want to hire an
accountant so bad and I like it look at
her she knows how much I hate it I [ __ ]
about it I [ __ ] about it to everyone
I'm sorry guys I'll keep bitching and I
literally because my dad says you need
to know your numbers you need to do this
like I just do it because he says and I
I don't want to do it and it's like
that's the level of respect men want to
have from us it's like so much that even
when you disagree even when you don't
want to do it you just do it because you
love them and you respect them and it's
someone that you trust so much you know
that they would never like abuse you
yeah like that's that's the type of like
relationship we aspire to have yeah it's
like it because it has to be someone you
trust yeah I feel like I have just never
had that so I think that's where the con
the concert talk can get triggering
because you're like well what the [ __ ]
like if I can't talk to you about the
nail salon I'm gonna go hang on my
friends I actually need to have a life I
can't completely trust in your judgment
because I can't completely trust you
like yeah I
do not have a man in my life or really
ever really had when I said maybe to one
but even then
um so if it's not a [ __ ] yes of the [ __ ]
no right so it's like I've never had a
guy where I feel like yeah if he says
don't go I'm not going so and so and
that's what is where I'm working on
myself to where I can manifest someone
like that because
clearly like there there's something
inside of me that's attracting these
type of men to where it's like I need to
correct something in here well and it's
making the men of the future pay for the
mistakes of your past yeah and so it's
like it's not his fault that you grew up
how you grew up it's not his fault like
who you've dated before yeah and it's
like we always hate when a guy comes in
and we date him and he's like you're
cheating on me you know what I'm saying
like he's all up in our phone and like
all this stuff and you're like
we can think of someone but we do it to
men all the time where it's like we
can't submit because we're thinking oh
we might do what that guy did or that
guy did where it's like a good like a
good if a good solid man came in like
someone who loved you respected you and
wanted what was best for you said
something you're going to be questioning
him and it's gonna throw like it's gonna
drive him off yeah and with that said
though I'm not gonna lie I Look to have
um the man that I want for my future is
a man that can Inspire and teach me
that's why you want a unicorn I've
talked I want the Unicorn because I Am a
Unicorn can I say but I do want a man
that when I say but babe why can't I go
though
and he'll be like look what if he said
just trust me
I would do that even just trust me babe
just trust me I would like you sure cool
then I'll trust you it's just a
reassurance just how women have
intuition men men have intuitions that
we can't understand just how they can't
understand our intuition but with
something you said earlier do not about
how you like to cook for people because
it's just something you love to do and
you love to have that experience with
them and it made me think about what
Andrew Tate was saying earlier about how
when a man is able to I think I can't
remember exactly what he said but did he
use the word inspire or he uses some
word but when a man is able to be that
to a woman that is like you cooking for
your man it's like that that feeling
that you get like oh it's like a sense
of just like
oh yeah like I love doing that for you
and that's how men are they want to be
able to be in that space where it's like
only a man can be and be able to do that
because they love doing that and that's
just innate in them yeah do you know
what I think though is a bit of a
problem
I mean well like I've said I've had good
exes they've been good communicators but
then you guys say oh if a man's
ambitious he's got this whatever going
on he doesn't have time to listen to you
I think that's not right because like I
said I've had exes that want to
communicate with me so it's like it is
possible because they are men you said
remember remember I listened to your
words yeah and you said your ex has
lacked ambition bums love to listen
moms are great communicators well Market
okay okay low ambition men my point is
that they love to listen
they're very impossible the reason these
I value men feel like they don't need to
be good communicators is because we
women are letting them accept it we're
accepting that it's okay for you yeah
but you're communicating you're trying
to because you're going to understand it
you're going to men and saying why
aren't you perfect like that that's
essentially what you do like you want
you want perfect that's okay okay okay
again again again okay look it look it
okay okay so my my dad again I I've
grown up I know these men okay not not
not the entertainers the athlete them I
do not know but but the businessman
right like the one percent like
businessman I grew up around them they
work 60 70 hours a week do you want to
come home from working 12 hours a day
now you walk through the door babe do
you Boo this is what happened to me this
is what happened to that that and that
and then did it also I have this problem
with you also why can't you and then
he's like why are you not listening to
me babe so it's like he's he's working
his ass off all day trying to provide
for you and now on top of that he has to
be your therapist and now you might not
look at it as therapy but this is how
the men see it but I've had men I have
had rich men that do have time it's just
unfortunately I didn't like them but
okay what what is what did they what did
they do okay what wait okay so what what
did you what did they do what what did
they do what do you mean what did they
do what was the what did the rich man do
oh they had business they had a business
you know yeah he had his thing going on
the point is I just didn't like him but
he community so again so again again
this goes this this again again this
this goes back to like watch what women
say not what they do because if I'm
hearing to you if he's rich and he's
emotionally available that sounds like a
golden ticket that sounds like unicorn
okay okay but this is what this is
awesome but to me to me again so the men
would hear this and they would say well
she goes on dates with men that aren't
their types what's she doing to me like
this is this is how the men see it
they're gonna get to pick the men we won
no no you do you do so so if a man if a
man asks me on a date I have the option
to say yes or no so you do and I don't
know what Anthony Joshua and I know it's
Anthony Joshua okay okay okay okay okay
my point is I'm telling you I'm just
telling you how the men will see it so
they hear this and they're now you're a
user you use men for their resources
because you're taking this man it's time
and attention and possibly money okay
okay okay okay okay but I'm saying
somebody this is how that's what it
looks like that's what it looks like but
I don't care so so um I'm saying you you
you're a pretty girl you're 26 you're
not you're not 36 you're 26. you
absolutely get to choose they're they're
but I'm not gonna do like that's one so
I don't care how good looking you are
okay I don't care I can't deal with
[ __ ] I can't do that okay but you
told me you say it Okay okay then die
okay okay then okay okay okay all right
look at me look at me look at me look at
me look at me look at me die alone
it's so ironic that that she's saying I
can't deal with [ __ ] I can't deal
with the man that can't communicate and
he said the money said I can't deal with
[ __ ] I can't deal with a woman
that's going to change my to chew my ear
off about these things usually and let
me tell you what you want to talk wait
wait wait wait wait let me tell you
something and on top of that as a high
value woman I'm not gonna lie as a high
value woman you really hardly have time
to be discussing things that are so
futile if anything what you're going to
discuss with your mom when you come home
from A Hard Day's work or anything be
like do you know what babe I'm having
this issue logistically I'm trying to
figure this out in my business I'm
trying to do this what the hell do I do
those are the sort of problems I could
actually get a man involved in those are
the sort of things that as women of
today we kind of should concern
ourselves with a little bit more we are
no longer in high school I don't know
why we're having beef on a nail salon I
don't know why we always get ourselves
involved
it depends on the kind of friend that
you are to him who wants to have a
friend that is constantly draining you
with pointless uh issues I cut my
friends I cut girls off my friend group
because they drain my ears with nonsense
about nonsense and that is really
annoying and that's one of the things
that sometimes I say to girls and I say
to my friends I say to my friends around
me I say this you are the reason why men
hate girls you are the reason why men
will cheat because they're there Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam and I say the middle thing a
million times as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible